[Music]
what comes to mind when you think about
research
probably a laboratory with test tubes
microscopes and scientists wearing white
lab coats
this setup is ideal for researchers in
some disciplines
such as virologists studying viral
infections
physicists developing new electronic
devices
or chemists creating new materials other
possibilities
such as someone digging through
historical archives
or someone distributing surveys about
consumer preferences may also come to
mind
that's research too so what is research
what unites these very different
approaches they share the same
fundamental goal
the creation of new knowledge or ideas
every good research project begins with
a question that has no known answer
these questions vary from field to field
a research product can be something
tangible such as a new drug for curing a
particular disease
or it can be intangible such as a new
understanding of an archival text
many people associate the idea of
research with the scientific method
a cyclical process of posing questions
and reaching conclusions
the first step in this process is making
observations
and asking questions
then the researcher formulates
hypotheses or educated guesses
that try to answer those questions and
develops experiments to collect data
and produce results the results help the
researcher to form a conclusion
the final step of the scientific method
is sharing the results of the research
with other scholars
so that they can observe verify and ask
their own
questions this process is an ongoing
loop that pushes discovery and
innovation forward
but the processes and principles of the
scientific method aren't limited to the
sciences
when a literary scholar reads a number
of texts by authors writing in the same
time period
and notices thematic similarities
they're making observations
when they ask why these themes are
important to the writers in this time
period
they're asking a research question
then they might argue that the
particular themes they are seeing
are a result of certain economic or
social conditions
that characterize that time period this
is a hypothesis
in order to collect data the scholar can
read more texts from that time period
and contrast them with texts from other
periods to see if there are sufficient
similarities and differences
finally they can publish their work and
allow other scholars to study it
and ask their own questions maybe you
have a burning question that you'd like
to solve
or perhaps you're itching to join an
existing research team
luckily there are numerous ways that you
can get involved with research
one pathway that leads to a career in
research involves attending college and
eventually pursuing an advanced degree
such as a phd
but even people who don't have a college
education can contribute to research
projects
for instance by participating in surveys
or helping researchers gather data
through research you can contribute to
tackling major obstacles of our
generation
from conserving endangered species to
monitoring public health crises
as long as you're curious and
hardworking research is for you
[Music]
you